hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be looking at the candidates
tournament we're in round six of the
candidates tournament this is a 14 round
tournament
and the winner of this we'll go on to
face magnus carlsen early next year for
the world championship our competitors
today white's gonna be played by ali
reza one of the favorites in this
tournament the definitely person that
magnus carlson wants to face for the
world championship and black's gonna be
played by fabiana caruana who has won
this tournament in the past now they're
definitely having different tournaments
so far fabiano is in second place only a
half a game behind jannepo who won it
last time and alireza although he is in
many minds the favorite for this
tournament he is in last place but that
can be somewhat deceiving he's only one
point behind fabiano who's in second if
ali reza with the white pieces wins
today will actually be tied with fabiano
so while we're only in around six this
starts to mean a lot to these players so
let's go ahead and get started with all
your res and the white pieces starts out
with d4 knight f6 from fabiano c4 then
e6 g3 getting into the catalan opening
with bishop g2 and then we have bishop
e7 now this is the closed catalan you
have the open if the pawn takes on a c4
but fabian decides to go for the closed
variation with bishop e7
now we have knight f3 castle on the
king's side and
white responds with queen d3 i thought
this was pretty interesting because the
main lines you typically see pawn takes
d5 castle on the king's side
get king safety or just knight c3 but
decides to go ahead and get his queen
involved into the game with queen d3
pawn c5 there is going to be an exchange
after castle on the d4 square then after
knight c6 we see the knights come off
the board as well and then knight to d5
nice little outpost both sides have one
central pawn on the e file the c and the
d file are open up so you will start to
see both sides getting their rooks
involved into the game trying to control
these long open files rook to d1 so ali
reza starts that with
getting his rook to the d file bishop f6
attacking the queen queen comes over
here g4 could have played more of a
passive move but he decides if i get my
queen involved into the game i want to
keep it engaged so queen g4 still
attacks the king side of the board here
bishop d7 getting the bishop involved
also just opening up for the rook to
come to c8 controlling that c file as we
talked about knight to d2 needs to get
both of the rook uh both the rooks
involved into the game so first needs to
get his knight involved and then
eventually his bishop as well queen e7
knight f3 rook to c8 as we predicted and
then pawn e4 and i thought this was a
pretty crucial move because my initial
thought did not see
how fabiano could get out of this
because knight really needs to move out
of the way can't come to f4 that's just
gonna die to the pawn here but if it
comes to you know c7 that's pretty
awkward with the move e5 attacking the
bishop where does the bishop move can't
just take here it's defended by the
knight and if it comes to either g5 or
h4 h4 it is going to fall to the knight
that's protected by the queen but
fabiano correctly found the move e5 and
that stops it you may say well yeah you
just take the knight here yes but this
is a discovered attack with the bishop
attacking the queen
solo reza is forced to move the queen
queen h5
now after knight to b4 since it is still
under attack by the pawn we see bishop
to g5 attacking the queen
bishop takes knight comes to a g5 now we
do have a mate threat queen takes on 87
would be checkmate fabiano can't let
that happen so h6 now the knight comes
back to f3
knight c6 just positioning a little bit
better it wasn't doing much on the b4
square so it comes back to c6 and if it
wants to eventually come back to
d4 it has that option with a new outpost
remember before it was on the d5 square
but since the pawns move the outpost has
changed as well and this is where things
get spicy so
this bishop on d7 ali reza says you know
what i'm in last place it's time to
shock the world and let people know that
i came to play decides to sacrifice his
rook and take the bishop on
d7 after the queen takes we do have
bishop h3 so able to get back some
material this is attacking the queen and
behind it the rook
fabiano does have the move pawn f5 to
stop it so it does allow him to get a
pawn in material but he is still down a
pawn in the exchange if you think about
a bishop being worth three points in a
pawn being worth one point he did give
up five points from the rook so he is
down
curious to see how he uses this uh with
his game plan
rook two e8 so fabiano's now in the game
playing up just hold the four do not
lose to whatever shenanigans ali reza is
trying to play and he should do well in
the end game knight 2 h4
pawn e4 just pushing that a little bit
more rook to d1 finally getting that
rook involved into the game queen over
two f7 says hey if you want to trade off
that's going to be good for me anytime
you're up in material you want to trade
off as much material as possible holly
rosa recognizes that is not going to be
the game plan that wins for him so queen
back to e2
and then fabiano gobbles up more
material here on a2 so now he's only
down
uh
or has now exchanged the bishop for his
opponents rook
ali reza will be looking to get some of
that material back you can see it's kind
of difficult like how does he continue
in this setup i'm curious what he was
thinking when he gave up that rook but
we'll see how play continues knight to
g6 attacking the rook rook f7 knight
comes back to f4 queen to b3
bishop to g4 here and then pawn down e3
king g2 and if you look at and say you
know why does the king need to come to
g2 one of the threats that white had
after playing bishop g4 is the move
bishop h5 it pins down the rook on f7 to
the other rook looks like he can gobble
up one of these rooks so that's the
whole reason he played bishop to g4 but
he can't do that right away because
of the move pawn takes on f2 check now
after the the queen takes here
then the rook can come down to f5
and
this rook's actually protected the
bishop can't take it because now the
queen can just come down take the rook
on d1 check and white is going to lose
so while it looks immediately like yeah
well the queen and the bishop are both
protecting this rook that would actually
be a mistake to think that and so the
king comes to g2 for safety and
recognizing that he just can't play
bishop h5 right away
so now fabian allen decides to go and
play rook to d8 does not want to have to
worry about the bishop coming to h5 and
also completely fine just exchanging
material remember he's up in material so
exchanging down is going to be a good
thing rook takes on d8 knight takes and
then the pawn takes on e
three rook over to c7 so alireza was
able to get one pawn back but he still
is down to material from he's given up a
rook
and he's gotten a bishop and pawn in
exchange king comes to h3 knight to f7
here
bishop f3 attacking the rook the rook
comes down to c2 attacking the queen
and then queen down to d1
now knight to
g5 and this is extremely important
because if not
knight to g5 maybe you look at and say
well why didn't he just capture material
on b2 well this would be a mistake
because queen d7
and this kind of even things up let's
say we now have knight takes g5 remember
black used one of his moves to come over
and capture the pawn on b2
well now this is just going to to be a
drawn game because after king g4
uh then
maybe the knight comes down f3 bob but
there's just going to be an ongoing
series of checks now if the queen comes
to g8 to stop it doesn't really matter
knight to g6 and just gonna be checking
all the game along so fabiano does have
to be careful that he does not have a
perpetual check because he's currently
winning does not want to end up drawing
the game so uh after the queen comes to
d1 instead of taking the pawn on b2 he
knows he can get that material at any
point but he needs to keep the pressure
up so knight to g5
check and then after the king to g4 now
decides to play
knight two f three
now queen d8 as we talked about but it's
a little bit different than before
because after
king two h7 the king this queen on d8
can't come to the critical square of g6
remember before it came to d7
and then it came to e8 which allowed it
to come to g6 it can't do that because
it's currently on the d8 square so white
first takes the knight on f3 but then
black takes the pawn on b2 and it's very
difficult to see how white's going to
continue and get a victory out of this
position
fabian now decides to play rook to d8
does not want his rooks to be on the
same diagonal being attacked by the
bishop here also decides hey yeah if you
want to exchange some material from your
rook that's fine with me i'm up in
material this is gonna be good white
decides to go in exchange knight comes
back to the eighth the only good thing
for white although you don't want to
trade down is now the knight is not very
active at all uh it has gonna take a few
moves for the night to get back in the
action uh maybe alireza is looking to
pounce on that first decides to go ahead
and take the pawn on e3 so does get a
pawn back in material he's now traded
off a rook for a bishop and a pawn
but it is still difficult to turn that
into an advantage rook to c7 king h3
knight f7 and then after bishop to f3
then you see the rook come down to c2
attacking the queen the queen comes down
to a d1 and then we see the move knight
to g5 and this is an important move
because a lot of players may make the
mistake of yeah i can just play knight
g5 but that's check and my opponent can
move uh they're king so i'll just go
ahead and take this material on b2 just
gobble up as much material as possible
unfortunately if black does not keep up
the pressure with check
then this could very easily end up in a
drawn game queen to
d7 and this is an even game if you run
it through the engine and see who's
winning uh it says that both sides are
equal and part of the reason for that is
it's very easy for white to have a
perpetual check here maybe now knight to
d or excuse me to g5 check okay well now
just king 2 g4 and then after the night
coming down to
uh f3 you have queen e8 and this is
perpetual check there's no way to get
out of it yes they could eventually
bring their queen into the game but then
after knight to g6 there's no way to
really stop the checks from from going
back and forth so fabiano has to be
aware of that
and says you know what i'm not going to
fall for that mistake instead of playing
rook takes on b2 i am just going to keep
up the pressure with knight to g5 check
so king g4
knight comes down takes the bishop on f3
now we have queen to d8
king 2 h7 and this is very different
before the queen came to d7 and then it
came to queen
to e8 and it could easily come to g6 and
that would be the perpetual chick that
we talked about on d8 it is a little bit
trickier because it is going to take a
few moves so first the king is going to
take the knight on f3
queen now takes on b2 capturing that
pawn that fabiano knew he could take at
any time and now queen e8 now this is
preparing for the move queen g6 as we
talked about fabiano has to block that
so he plays queen f6
you can start to see from white
standpoint really difficult to see how
he's going to continue and get a victory
out of this very ambitious to give up
the rook
without in my opinion a clear path to an
attack definitely opened things up and
made it interesting but now we're at a
point where fabiano defended correctly
and it just seems tough for white to
continue in the spot does play pawn e4
rook over to
h2 gobbling up that pawn in material so
now fabiano getting more of a material
advantage here
queen down to d7
queen c3
attacking the king king g4 and then
after queen d2 we have queen a4 now reza
decided to resign in this position many
times people ask well how would play
continue why did he resign well
first and foremost h5 is probably the
deadly move that fabiano would play if
play continued this is check how do you
really continue from here if you take
with your knight it's very difficult to
hold on to that night because now the
queen and the rook are both attacking
together this is check maybe you could
play rook to f2 in this spot
eventually you are going to
gobble up that knight in material so
just not going to end well so decides
you know what i'm playing fabiano he's
probably not going to make that mistake
so after the move queen to a4
decides to go ahead and resign in this
spot so fabiano congratulations to him
still in second place only a half game
behind yanepa because jonepo also won uh
his game against jkd
um so that was a fascinating game as
well i've been really excited about this
particular matchup because so many
people were hyped about ali reza myself
included
disappointed to see he is still in last
place with only two points we'll need a
strong run over the next eight rounds if
anyone can do it you can see he's an
exciting player always willing to take
chances
but definitely in a tough spot right now
hopefully you guys enjoy this coverage
of round six and the 2022 candidates
tournament let me know if you have
feedback on any matchups you want to
make sure that i cover in this
tournament or just any other feedback in
general thanks again for watching i'll
see you guys in the next video
you